my favorite memory about Baywatch was
the music when when it first starts
digit et and then the music but that was
my favorite part it was like my calling
and to watch everyone run in slow motion
Priyanka came so close to living out her
own slow motion beach scene but turns
out she's not playing a lifeguard
she's the villains a big scene and there
is uh there's a villain who's got a gun
pointed at me but it's not just any
villain it's not just any person there's
only one woman in the world that can
handle this kind of pressure this kind
of action there's evil never looks so
cool
evil looks incredible Priyanka and the
rock really get into the whole
trash-talking frenemy thing I know
you're not used to this mr. rock but I
smell what you're cooking okay so watch
out cuz I got you you going down and he
was like oh yeah Priyanka plays the
villainous Victoria the opposite of her
role as FBI recruit Alex Parrish on
Quantico
my role in Quantico doesn't help me as
Victoria at all Victoria is the complete
opposite she doesn't get her hands dirty
because she has a manicure and she's
like somebody else does the dirty work
you